l'objectif est vraiment de relier le
coeur historique de maurepas avec ses
frangins agricole pour véritablement
faire pénétrer la nature dans la ville
et dans le projet le programme et ixia
c'est le premier exemple du renouveau de
la zone d'activités paris ouest à
maurepas le projet mené en deux phases a
débuté par le déménagement de
l'enseignent qui habitent dans des
nouveaux locaux sur ces premières étapes
vous avez concrètement la mutation donc
d'une ancienne qui était jadis qui
habille le magasin kiabi qui s'est
transféré juste en face avec un
découpage en quatre autres cellules donc
in fine est vous avez cinq cellules sur
la première étape on a mixé à la fois
des enseignes nationales et des porteurs
de projets plus à plus locaux trois des
quatre enseignes qui seront présentes
sont déjà connus afflelou chausséa et
die by day et xl et dans la tente d'un
dernier entrepreneurs pour compléter
l'espace le parking et la zone de
déchets seront communs pour les cinq
magasins l'objectif est de mutualiser
tous sains et de rendre véritablement le
parti pris et la place primordiale de
l'humain dans son usage et dansons dans
sa consommation des espaces d'où là d'où
l'importance du marqueur végétal qui va
dominer ou si le projet le projet dans
son intégralité
superviser et accompagnés par les maires
de maurepas et coignières grégory
gastier et didier fischer ce premier
projet s'inscrit dans une vision plus
large des zones commerciales paris-ouest
forum jb les portes de chevreuse les
autres zones d'activités économiques se
rassemblent d'ailleurs dans le dans le
secteur nous on souhaite vraiment avoir
un positionnement différent différent
puisqu'on est à la lisière de forêt de
jeunes agricoles importantes notamment
sur sur coignières on a le village de
maurepas qui est pas loin donc d'avoir
une identité très forte un
positionnement qu'on se sente bien dans
cette zone d'activités avec ses vingt
mille mètres carrés le programme éthique
cela ne représente pourtant que 18% de
la zone paris ouest le plus grand espace
d'activités de l'ouest parisien